Hey youtubers it’s charlie and welcome to
part 2 of my Walking Dead Season 4 countdown.
We’re just celebrating the return with a
short video series just to get pumped up again.
This time I thought it would be fun to talk
about our biggest questions before episode
9.
There are a few clues that tie in with episode
titles including the finale.
I’ll also talk about some things AMC is
super worried about after the list.
Careful for potential spoilers if you don’t
want to know anything.
I’ll be doing weekly episode videos starting
sunday along with Q&As and giveaway videos
mondays.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I’ll explain the giveaway again before it
starts.
So biggest walking dead questions number 10:
Who killed that rabbit in episode 8?
My best guess based on her character arc in
the first half of the season is lizzie.
She started of as this really pure little
girl and Carol started to shout the tears
out of her.
Worst IRL parent ever but BEST walking dead
parent ever.
She was even able to shoot someone without
freaking out in episode 8.
Number 9: Where did that giant herd of walkers
go from episode 3.
There had to have been at least 5 to 10 thousand
walkers stretched as far as the eye could
see.
They didn’t just disappear.
Walkers will generally seek out nearby food,
but in order to travel in a large group like
that over a long distance, someone had to
be influencing them.
The quick guess is that it’s related to
the villain of the second half of the season.
The governor is gone, so a new big bad will
fill that vaccum of evil soon.
Number 8: Who was the voice on the other end
of Daryl’s radio.
The best theories I’ve seen are that it’s
sanctuary.
There’s no guarantee that they’ll find
it this season, but now that they’re looking
for new shelter.
Darryl’s group will probably start tracking
down the signal.
Number 7: Who was on the bus and who ran into
the woods.
Glenn and Maggie were on the bus, but then
Maggie got stuck with Bob Stokey and Sasha
trying to find Beth.
So I think we can call the bus group Glenn’s
Group.
Number 6: Who was feeding the rats?
Short answer, probably lizzie.
But since she kind of checked out mentally
over the course of the season she might not
have been hardcore enough during episode 1,
I also think Carol or a new person could have
done it.
But Right now, based on the Dead Rabbit evidence,
I think that Lizzie is the best guess.
Number 5: What happened to lilly?
The last time we saw her she was still alive
and hadn’t been bitten.
She had just killed her better half but I
think she made it into one of the groups fleeing
into the woods on foot.
That means Tyreese’s group or maggie’s
group.
I think rick and carl will be on their own.
Number 4: Is baby Judith Dead?
Beth got off the bus to go get her, and the
car seat was unbuckled.
So it’s possible that she or someone else
who was injured grabbed her and ran.
My earlier theory was that it was Tyreese
who looked like he was carrying something
while running away.
Episode 9 will probably reveal what happened
so we won’t have to wait long for an answer.
Number 3: Who is the new villain?
Episode 9 will be all about the aftermath
of the governor’s attack, so we won’t
meet the new villain for a few episodes.
The best theory is that it will be an amalgam
of a couple characters from the comic book.
I’ll post a link at the end of the video
for details on that.
Number 2: Will they reach sanctuary.
In the comic books this is the next place
they travel to.
And based on the timeline at least some of
the prison group will make it there.
I’m betting daryl’s group will make it
first, just because he was the one to hear
the garbled transmission.
The voice said sanctuary.
So i think that’s a dead giveaway.
Number 1: Will they reach the alexandria safe
zone.
This is one of the bigger questions and the
season finale is called “A”.
It’s also possible that the show will mash
both the sanctuary and the safe zone into
one location.
So let me know what your biggest question
is for the second half of the season.
I’ll be doing weekly q&a’s for all the
episodes, so my next one will just be next
week after episode 9.
Now let’s talk about some of the things
AMC the network is really worried about.
Scott Gimple said recently that the show is
going to get waay darker in the second half.
Like a major character death and perpetrating
some horrors as yet unseen in the past 3 seasons.
So he said AMC is freaking just a little because
they don’t want to lose their audience.
Personally I think most people watch Walking
Dead understanding that it’s supposed to
make you feel a little sick.
I think that’s just the test of being a
human being.
But here’s a big question.
Is there anything Walking Dead could do to
any of the characters that would make you
stop watching.
Bad or Good.
It doesn’t just have to be someone dying.
Now for giveaway details again.
I think I’m going to change the rules just
to make it easier.
Originally it was going to be guessing the
deaths in each episode.
But I think I’ll just pick a random subscriber
from the comments and just give the $20 giftcard
away.
I’ll still be doing a q&a video every monday
after I post review videos.
And I’ll still do a third bonus video.
I think it will just be a top 5 deaths video.
Sometimes the walker kills get pretty epic
so that should be fun.
Right now click here for my top 10 predictions
this season and click here for all my superbowl
trailer videos.
They were all pretty cool.
Thanks for watching.
See you guys tonight.
High Fives!